es ist heute ja wirklich ein
historischer tag um 22 uhr 33
mitteleuropäischer sommerzeit wird zum
ersten mal seit neun jahren wieder ein
bemanntes raumschiff von amerikanischem
boden ausstatten und zwei astronauten
zur iss bringen
es ist der beginn einer neuen ära der
raumfahrt der erste schritt richtung
einer mondstation dem flug zum mars eine
neue stufe der eroberung des weltalls
wenn corona nicht noch dazwischen funkt
hier sind alle fakten zu diesen
spektakulären raumflug bei pixum science
fiction hier gibt es drei mal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen was für ein tag wie er bei
pixum science fiction haben diesen
moment seit jahren entgegengefiebert und
heute um 22 uhr 30 hiesiger zeit soll er
realität werden wenn das wetter
mitspielt wenn nicht dann wird das
epochale ereignis auf den 30 geschoben
es ist wirklich der absolute wahnsinn
endlich gehen werden eine neue phase der
raumfahrt astronautinnen astronauten
wenn jetzt nicht mehr mit antiquierten
sojus kapseln aus den 60er jahren sei es
fliegen sondern mit der hochmodernen
cousin und zwar wurde die sojus-kapsel
über die jahre immer weiter entwickelt
aber die grundkonstruktion blieb die
crew drängen dagegen scheint aus einem
science-fiction-film zu entstammen so
hoch modern ist die raumkapsel
ausgestattet und kapsel ist eigentlich
das falsche wort sieben personen haben
platz in dem raumschiff und das
raumschiff wird jetzt auch zeitgemäß mit
einem joystick gesteuert man möchte
sagen endlich unendlich werden raumflüge
auch bezahlbar
denn bisher verschlangen raum
staatsmilliarden nur die russen mit
ihren betagten sojus kapseln konnten es
einigermaßen kostengünstig machen 80
millionen dollar pro passagier wurden
von der russischen weltraumagentur
roskosmos dafür veranschlagt 60
millionen sollen es jetzt bei der crew
decken seien ein apollo flug
verschlangen noch mehr als eine
milliarde dollar kein wunder die
trägerrakete die saturn 5 gehört mit
ihrer höhe von 110 metern noch immer zu
den größten raketen der welt der staat
gewicht lag bei 2000
880 tonnen das dreistufige trägersystem
hatte eine schubkraft von 160 millionen
ps und die saturn 5 erreicht eine
spitzengeschwindigkeit von 39.000
kilometern pro stunde zum mond zu
fliegen ist halt noch mal ein anderer
schnack aber auch die space shuttles die
eigentlich auch wegen ihrer
wiederverwendbarkeit die raumfahrt
endlich kostengünstig machen sollten
waren ein groschengrab 208 milliarden
dollar gab die nasa für 135 flüge aus
das waren pro flug 1,5 milliarden dollar
absurd das wird jetzt mit der crew
dragon anders hintergrund ist die
wiederverwendbarkeit der meisten
komponenten die trägerrakete und das
raumschiff kehren wieder zur erde zurück
und sind so robust gebaut dass sie
wiederverwendet werden können das ist
eine wirkliche neue ära der raumfahrt
und heute um 22 33 14 beginnen bob
winken und doug hurley das sind die
beiden erfahrenen astronauten die schon
das spaceshuttle geflogen haben und
jetzt die crew dragon steuern
sie werden mit einem weißen tesla model
s wie sie sich für spacex gehört zur
legendären startrampe 39a der nasa
gefahren genau der startrampe von der
die apollo kapsel vor 50 jahren richtung
mond ab oben und dann steigen sie aus
einem futuristischen gefährtin ein
absolut futuristisches gefährt und das
über einen ziemlich futuristischen gang
den space ex und tesla chef elon musk an
die startrampe hat bauen lassen alles
hier strahlt den neuen geist der
raumfahrt aus endlich und wirklich
endlich wird hier planmäßig und
effizient raumfahrt gemanagt endlich
laufen die kosten nicht mehr dramatisch
aus dem ruder und machen das ganze
unterfangen und realistisch niemand wird
heute mehr 1,5 milliarden für einen raum
flug zur iss und auch nicht zum mond
ausgeben die zukunft der raumfahrt ist
futuristisch und gleichzeitig ökonomisch
ein wahnsinns schritt für die menschheit
und der ist eben auch optisch und
technisch in der korrekten zu sehen bis
zu sieben passagiere haben in dem
raumschiff platz mehr als auf die uss
passen also die internationale
raumstation und auch hier zeigt sich das
raumschiff wurde für die zukunft geplant
mit dieser kapazität kann eine große
crew
auf den mond gebracht werden das ziel
der nasa für 2024 dann soll dort zum
ersten mal seit rund 50 jahren wieder
einer und dieses mal eine astronautin
die mondoberfläche betreten und dann
soll dauerhaft ja man kann fast sagen
die besiedlung des mondes staaten erst
mit einer mondstation die um den mond
kreist um zwei inder umlauf waren
die sich auch immer wieder der erde
nähert so dass die station schon in der
nähe der erde angeflogen werden kann
und dann ist die nächste stufe eine
dauerhafte station auf der
mondoberfläche
da gibt es ja zahlreiche pläne wir haben
ja vor kurzem berichtet tatsächlich ist
es so dass eine besatzung dort relativ
autark leben und arbeiten könnte wasser
gibt es auf dem mond in form von eis aus
dem kann dann sauerstoff und auf
treibstoff gewonnen werden mit dem
wasserstoff und auch die versorgung mit
nahrungsmitteln dürfte nach den jüngsten
experimenten in der antarktis dort
problemlos klappen und diese station
könnte tatsächlich mit einem aufzug mit
einer station im mond orbit verbunden
werden was ich demnächst in meinem buch
per aufzug ins weltall das im herbst
endlich erscheinen dort beschreibt
plötzlich mit dem heutigen tag rückt die
zukunft ein stück näher
plötzlich wird so vieles greifbar nah
die besiedlung des mondes die erste
bemannte mission zum mars die raumfahrt
steht wirklich vor einem epochalen
schritt in die zukunft dabei war nicht
immer alles so rosig aus erst vor
ziemlich genau einem jahr und einem
monat explodierte eine crew dragon
getestet wurden die booster der kuh
decken mit denen die kapsel im notfall
in der lage wäre sich von der falken
trägerrakete zu lösen und selbstständig
notzulanden kurz nach dem start zum
beispiel die explosion war so stark dass
sie damals sogar auf satellitenaufnahmen
zu sehen war das problem ist dass diese
rettungs triebwerke mit einem
hochgiftigen extrem explosiven
treibstoff betrieben werden es handelt
sich um eine hyper wurde treibstoff
mischung aus die stickstoffdioxid und
einer hydrazin variante die vorteile
solcher kraftstoffe sie müssen nicht wie
herkömmliche treibstoffe gezündet werden
sondern reagieren sofort miteinander was
sie für ein notfallsystem zu einem
idealen treibstoff macht zudem müssen
sie nicht gekühlt werden der nachteil
sie sind eben extrem exklusiv und
hochgiftig sprich auch die moderne
raumfahrt ist nicht vor unglücksfällen
und rückschlägen gefeit raumfahrt ist
einfach technik am limit technik an den
grenzen unserer möglichkeiten und sie
wird am lebensfeindlich ssten ort den
wir kennen eingesetzt im weltall
auch die apollo-mission musste mit
schlimmen rückschlägen damals kämpfen
der anfang der apollo-missionen war eine
schlimme tragödie drei astronauten
sollten einen monat vor dem ersten flug
der apollo 1 millionen die raumkapsel
testen
doch die ingenieure hatten eine
technische schwachstelle übersehen
einige werfen der nasa sogar vor im
rennen um die erste mondlandung
nachlässig geworden zu sein denn auch
die russen waren quasi am start mit der
n1 rakete die aber dann zwei fehlstarts
hingelegt hatte es gab ein feuer im
cockpit bei der apollo und der
hundertprozentige sauerstoff in der
kapsel ließ die drei männer in sekunden
verbrennen danach wurde die gesamte
apollo kapsel noch mal auf herz und
nieren geprüft und zahlreiche änderungen
vorgenommen auch jetzt bei der crew
dragon mission war das der fall und sie
wurde immer wieder getestet und ständig
verbessert jetzt sollte also alles wie
am schnürchen laufen und wenn das wetter
eben keinen strich durch die rechnung
macht sollte es heute nacht bzw in cape
canaveral florida ist es 16 und 33 einen
bilderbuch start der demo zwei missionen
geben die wetterprognose sagt eine 60
prozentige wahrscheinlichkeit für gutes
stadt wetter voraus es ist die zweite
demonstration missionen der kecken
kapsel und schon die erste demo 1 war
anfang märz 2009 10 100 prozentige
erfolg zum ersten mal wurde damals mit
dem schrecken ein amerikanisches
raumschiff vollautomatisch an die iss
angedockt ein system dem die russische
weltraumorganisation roskosmos nicht so
richtig vertraute und ihren kosmonauten
iss kommandant oleg kotow menkow erwies
sich hinter vier geschlossenen schotten
in sicherheit zu bringen doch alles lief
glatt und die crew decken doppelt
besetzt mit einer puppe erfolgreich an
die gesamte mission soll jetzt auch
genauso reibungslos ablaufen allerdings
fürchtet auch die nasa corona das virus
darf auf keinen fall die internationale
raumstation iss erreichen denn dort
könnte ein schwerer krankheitsverlauf
schnell tödlich enden die beiden
astronauten hurley und binden gingen
deshalb am 13
tine mäßig wie vor jeder mission in
quarantäne doch dieses mal war einiges
anders aufgrund des corona virus wurden
einige zusätzliche schutzmaßnahmen
hinzugefügt beispielsweise werden alle
personen die während der quarantänezeit
vor ort sind oder mit der besatzung
interagieren auf temperatur und symptome
überprüft hurley und wenigen sowie
diejenigen die in direktem engen kontakt
mit der besatzung stehen werden
vorsichtshalber zwei mal auf das virus
getestet es ist also alles startklar für
eine wirklich legendäre mission und ich
werde auf jeden fall den start live
erfolge ich kann es euch auch nur ans
herz legen diesen historischen moment
live bei der nasa mitzuerleben der link
zum stream der inzwischen begonnen haben
dürfte oder in wenigen minuten der ist
hier verlinkt also mission control bitte
kommen draufklicken anschauen und den
youtube kanal der nase abonnieren bis
dann bleibt dran